[Music]
julie is with us julie is in tampa
florida hi julie welcome to the ramsay
show
hi guys how are you doing better than we
deserve what's up
awesome uh so so yeah my name is julie
i am 24 years old married my husband and
i both work full-time but he's also a
full-time paramedic student
um so my question is i am i'm at risk of
losing my job by thanksgiving they are
requiring a coveted vaccine for
in-person work by them and my husband
and i have kind of just opted out of
getting that
i'm on baby step number two i have two
more credit cards left to pay off but my
concern is if i'm out of work by
thanksgiving will i want to
put a hold off of paying off debt and
save every penny i get or do i want to
pay off more debt but have less really
wiggle room if i were to lose my job you
need to put your total money makeover on
hold and you know need to go get a new
job today yeah start looking right now
don't even wait for that shoe to drop
it's coming
it's coming and you've already made your
decision
and so you just need to act today
don't wait the the thing that can happen
is is that we live in uh we think that
uh
that the calvary is coming and someone's
gonna solve this for us
and they're not
they're not coming
yeah you know you really do know what's
going to happen so don't walk around
acting like it's not going to happen
yeah
and so it's time it's time for you to go
on and you need to go on today yeah you
don't need to wait on thanksgiving and
by the way julie this is a great job
market right now yeah so perfect timing
i mean you're going to get an upgrade
what do you make now
uh so what's funny is i've been working
at this company for two years but this
month i got promoted into a new role and
i make about 47 now with my raise code
what kind of work
um i was an executive assistant and now
i kind of work um
as a
low level consultant i would say within
the organization
correct yes okay
specializing know what operations
marketing um administration
yeah yeah well look uh you know how many
couples so you were such a good you're
such a good administrative assistant
that you're teaching the rest of them
now yeah
is that what it amounts to yeah yeah i
would say so okay yeah all right yeah so
you probably can land a position at
making 60 as a high-end administrative
assistant if you want to do that again
yeah because you've not only been you've
not only been a world-class assistant
you've also taught them
my fear is that a lot of companies are
going to be moving towards this new um
like in-person hybrid model which is
totally fine but having the mandated
vaccine within that is what scares me
there's some that are the big ones and
some but most of us aren't and do your
homework on the front end you can ask
around town you don't have just because
this because you've had this experience
at one place does not mean it's going to
be the norm
that's just not happening
it's only the big companies that are
optics concerned that are the huge mega
companies that are doing this stupid
butt stuff and the rest of them are
going no people are grown ups they get
to make their own decisions